it's the fourth nationwide protest since
may
thousands taking to the streets in 22
brazilian states
indigenous leaders joining forces with
left-wing parties trade unions and
social organizations
calling for president jair bolsonaro's
impeachment
they say brazilians must stand tall and
break the silence
74 year old akasui tapajara
says staying at home in fear of the
kovid 19 virus
is no longer an option
we're fighting for our lives in order to
do this we must
impeach the president who has done
nothing to protect us from the
coronavirus
but also from hunger and environmental
destruction
there's growing dissatisfaction with the
government's handling of the pandemic
which is now being investigated by
brazil's senate
bolsonaro was already being blamed for
downplaying the danger of the
coronavirus
and delaying the vaccine rollout in a
country
with the world's second largest number
of deaths by covid19
but the investigation took a turn when
congress started looking into
accusations of corruption
with government officials negotiating
overpriced vaccines
people are now also protesting because
they think that there is a risk to
democracy
this poster here says if the people are
out on the streets
in the midst of a pandemic it's because
the government
is more dangerous than the virus recent
polls show that
six out of every 10 brazilians asked
think bolsonaro is incapable of leading
the country
and that he would be defeated in next
year's election by former president
lula da silva responded
by following former u.s president donald
trump's script
i have already said that only god can
remove me
from the presidency like the former u.s
president
brazil's president has already started
telling his followers
that the opposition is going to rig the
election and that he won't accept the
results
if there is fraud there is an important
difference
regarding the us it's there in the u.s
the military did not get involved
and uh here they are involved uh it's
the first time since
1988 that military are clearly involved
in politics
and they have turned the uh the
democracy issue into a public policy
issue and it is not it's a
constitutional
issue and the military has not have
nothing to do with it
so i i think there is an imminent
an imminent threat to brazilian
democracy
through this conjunction this
this alliance between bolsonaro and
factions of
the military the presidential election
is still some way off but on the streets
of brazil
tensions are rising mauna keanakiev
al-jazeera
rio de janeiro